why are you dating what what is your end
goal from dating so I have to ask this
on a date so if I'm on a first no no no
why are you dating somebody why are you
going on dates what is what do you want
from dating to meet someone I like for
what what what's it what's the what's
the end game
husband right so you then have to when
you meet a guy you have to be explicit
and say to say to him I'm dating to be
married okay if he's not there to be
married then he's wasting your [ __ ]
time
but you don't guess you don't assume
[Music]
every time you meet somebody you just
drifting along
you might be around four or five years
so you've wasted a year of someone that
was never interested in getting married
to anyone in the first place yeah so if
you're not expressed about what you
expect as an outcome then how can you
outcomes you want you need to be you say
right this is what I want if you're not
on this plan then there's no point you
join you know no point you talk to me
because this is what I want at the end
of it yeah but like guys in the audience
don't you think it's a bit like a bit
overbearance on the first day if someone
says to you like oh like I want to get
married and someone has to kind of like
gauge if they want to get married
I said to you I am dating to be married
I'm only dating to be married but I
think like I was going to marry you but
I'm only dating change
a bit too high I feel like it makes it
puts a lot of pressure no no but you're
what you're doing is filtering the guys
who have no intention of being married I
guess
even even mentioning like the word
married would freak them out and it
would freak me out if a guy was like
yeah like I don't remember what does
Dana die and he was like oh like he was
talking about like a proposal like on
the first day yeah it really freaked me
out even though I was I had similar
intentions if you know what I mean I was
like you know the first thing you would
say like oh like I'm trying to get in a
relationship and then you know maybe a
few days later you can be like oh like
do you ever oh there we go yeah yeah
yeah
um maybe like oh like you know are you
maybe like looking to get married but
you wouldn't say it on the first date
actually that's not really a first date
discussion yeah then I'm gonna tell you
both you're very wrongly very floating
Never Gonna you know if that's what you
want you're not gonna get away with my
life you're gonna go for life just
drifting
I think men also have autonomy and like
what's going on in the relationship and
I feel like my man just like okay
because the woman hasn't said it
explicitly that she wants to get married
that it's off the table I'm like a man
should be able to also make that
decision as well so I feel like just
saying putting the whole thing in the
woman's hands is probably not fair you
missing something I'm not saying to you
God you want to marry you I'm not since
you're going to propose to him I'm just
going to make it clear for example I
don't want children right so whenever I
meet someone they make it absolutely
[ __ ] clear that it's not gonna happen
then why are you dating guys that
doesn't want to be married
well I don't know but you don't know
because you don't tell them that's what
that's what you want I guess do you
think that's common though I don't think
it's like no I'm etiquette for a first
date no no and I just well you floss why
women that's why you float that's why no
but I'm I'm talking about let me finish
um I'm talking about the people I know
that are married most of like my uh my
brother is I would say gonna get engaged
this year he's 28.
yeah he's like and the way like that he
him and his girlfriend just like met in
college dated for four or five years and
like now they're they bought a house
they're probably gonna get married
um and like same with my other brother
it was like the same thing
so I just like I don't know I'm not
saying you're wrong to be honest because
I actually like agree with you on some
level but like Devil's Advocate I don't
know anyone that did that that got
married and that's like my parents
that's how they met in college dated
four or five years yeah
different Generations so what I say to
you well this is like my brother's 28
like that's the same generation
yeah don't try it those trash is on you
she's on you don't try it she's Landing
a couple what I say in response to that
is this
um
so how would you react if someone said
like I want to get my intention is to
marry on the first date like how would
everyone react
what hey
I'm in a place
yeah like I'm sorry there was like what
is it I was on the first date and like
this guy he didn't even mention married
but he was like oh yeah like I'm trying
to like travel the world with my
significant other I'm like I'm like I
don't know you like why like what yeah
no for me it's like a time in a place is
not necessarily I I take it as face
value what I mean by that is
if uh someone tells it comes up to me
and like wait on a Thursday and says oh
I'm dating to get married cool
a big turn on personally for me is when
a woman knows like what she wants so if
I tell you time and a place I mean
really mean it's like look I'm looking
to get married in the next this amount
of time I'm looking to do it like this I
want this like I will know what I want
out of this out of a relationship and
stuff like that's a really big turn on
for me personally turn off I turn off
turn on Okay you know what you want out
of this relationship I know I wonder
when I go into a relationship I know
what I want I want you know I wanna I
wanna dates I want to you know have
someone to come back home to you to to
marry to love to have kids to build a
family in the next
eight years right but I know that right
and when a woman comes along with the
same energy that is just a really big
plus I guess it can work out really well
if you're both on the same level so if
the person also has like that same
intent and is very forward as well then
I think it makes a lot of sense but I
just don't think in the UK we have that
kind of culture to be that forward so it
just comes across a bit a bit strange
actually so you want to be married you
want to be married at some point not
that married man but like in a very
committed relationship
yeah I want to get married before
before
30 yeah okay probably yeah do you have a
time and place in mind eight years eight
years I was gonna say if you just
decided yeah
look uh when I first when I first
started thinking about this I was like
like very young yeah but like my me and
my friends like just like just joking
around and I said I was like I want to
be
have a kid unmarried like so when my kid
is born I can still be the you know the
cool dad you know someone that you know
that you know I don't want to be that
guy that's like oh Dad let's go throw a
balloon and I'm like oh Rusty like
walking around like yeah
I want to be active I want to you know
picking my son up and like outrun him in
a race and beat him and then talk [ __ ]
to him when he's young you know I want
to be that bad I don't want to be that
that sits on the couch with a drinking
beer and watching TV no she's speaking
facts speaking such a vivid picture so
ladies do and then people have like
friends in their 30s yes
yeah I don't think I do dear friends and
authorities that are unmarried but would
like to have been married already or
want to be married um foreign
so far I mean so far I don't really know
I think they want to have kids but they
don't necessarily want to get married
they're more like they've gone past that
point yeah I mean I don't know yeah we
haven't really had that discussion but I
mean she's single and she's dating
like all right like in kind of like
talking to someone you know like
whatever had someone but there's like a
marriage inflation with our generation
like I feel like every generation seems
to get married later and settle down a
bit later so I feel like we need to like
I feel like I should factor that in mind
and probably not want to get married so
early I think before 30 might be a bit
too much optimistic actually I think it
flawed defense I think I think your
opinion on that is flawed okay